no no the other before though oh
so basically yes it's very apparent that
like if you call I'm always picking up
if you text like I'm always attending to
you first like we're here and we're here
in Hawaii say for instance like you're
getting my master bedroom I'm sleeping
on the couch like you're always gonna be
first like your Comforts
um your needs are I am come first and I
don't know how to uh like
release it
from my brain
it's just habit at this point I think I
think it's just like a habit that I need
to break yeah yeah but I don't know well
you know if it's but if it's causing you
trouble in your relationships then it's
something we should address on
yeah but that's on me that's not you
well I do do the thing you know my mind
it's so good at it yeah I do have to do
mindful mental games you know yeah but
um
yeah we'll see you know
you know
so Carla anyone that's been hitting up
on Uriah well we were at dinner
yesterday and Bobby looked over at my
phone and he was like who else who else
do I have to start a war with uh here's
here's a new rule
what okay so everyone listen listen to
me right now okay
my friends
this is a message to my
friends okay
you all know right that clylla and I
dated for 10 years you all know we work
together she's one of my best friends I
love her and when she's on Raya and you
like her [__] that means you're going
behind my back and doing some say shady
[__] if you want to start a war with me
I'll [__] do the war okay
I've been so nice to you over the years
dude
no let's let's get real I've been so
[__] nice to you bro you know I mean
I like you
you're my friend but that's shady [__]
there's another one two he's much bigger
than you so I can't say his name but if
you're [__] listening to my friend
all right we cool we cool but not I mean
like I I you know I mean
there's another one too that's even
bigger than that one right right there's
another one that has a TV show right now
that guy right huh okay
wow yeah yeah so that's my point you
know I mean it's like it's not listen
there's a respect there's a there's a
there's a Code of Conduct it's just a
conversation too that's all it is you
guys and this is what I'll I'll say to
you guys
um
I am his concubine yes say it to the
camera though which camera I said it oh
he did okay yeah
I'm your concubine you know this is what
it is they people peop these comedians
right think that I'm a pushover because
I'm really nice
I'm a really nice guy at comedy club I'm
cool you know I mean uh you know I um
I don't know I I just have this I can
exude an element of my personality which
is like this kind of like what my
brother does of this confused naive you
know I'm a guy that doesn't know what's
going on but you have to number one I am
Korean right so I have a vindictiveness
and I love revenge and number two if you
get on my bad side I will war and I you
know I've been on in wars with people
for over 20 years you don't shy away I
don't shy away I will [__] double
down I will do I haven't played the La
Jolla Comedy Store in almost 20 years
because of one incident that happened
there yeah what was the incident again
he wouldn't put me up the [__] guy
Ryan at the comedy he's still there are
you still there yeah he wouldn't put me
up one night and I go if you don't put
me up tonight I'm never gonna play this
room again he goes that's fine so I go
and 20 years later I'm stubborn as [__]
I won't play it and they've asked you
yeah wow I will not play it okay so
right
watch it brother talented guy though but
it's just it's you know you know I um
there's another comic in New York you
know who's seeing
um this really hot girl and I had dinner
with